l'autre police la force de la proximité
de François Rabaté et Sébastien rocher
documentaire qui vous l'avez vu dresse
la liste des différentes formes de
police qui font aujourd'hui de la
proximité en lieu et place d'une police
qui a existé entre 98 et 2003 et que
certains regrettent est-ce le cas de nos
invités ici présent cela fait partie des
questions que nous allons leur poser
Jérôme Durin bienvenue à vous vous êtes
sénateur socialiste de la sonéloire
vice-président de la commission des lois
le 1er mai dernier dans le cadre d'un
débat sur nos force de l'ordre vous avez
suivi une brigade de la brave brigade de
répression de l'action violente et les
camérats de Public Sénat étaient là et
vous ont accompagné bris ortefeu
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
député européen ancien ministre de
l'intérieur sous le mandat de Nicolas
Sarkozi Virginie Malochet bienvenue à
vous vous êtes sociologue chargé
d'études senior à l'Institut Paris
Région et spécialiste des questions de
sécurité locale Denis Jacob bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes secrétaire
général du syndicat alternative police
CFDT merci merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre d'être ici et commençons tout de
suite par cette question posée dès le
début du film question qui plane
d'ailleurs au-dessus du débat public dès
qu'il y a des tensions dans notre
société dès qu'il y a des émeutes
était-ce une erreur de supprimer la
police de proximité Jérôme Durin oui
c'était une erreur on le
regrette et on ne cesse de se rendre
compte des effets de cette suppression
euh un syndicaliste d'unité SGP Police
fa
disait ce sont des mouvements lents dans
la police etce qu'on casse on met
beaucoup de temps à le reconstruire on
l'a vu avec ce qui s'est passé sous la
président Sarkozi avec la suppression de
9000 potes de policiers on achève à
peine de réparer ça et donc ce qui s'est
passé pour les effectifs de de policiers
ce qui s'est passé pour la police de
proximité bah il faut là aussi prendre
le temps de de le reconstruire et on en
a besoin aujourd'hui notamment pour
améliorer le rapport entre la police et
la population qui au cœur finalement de
tous les mots dont on parle dans le
débat public autour des questions de
sécurité brissorte feu écoutez je suis
pas tout à fait en accord avec ce qui je
viens d'entendre je dis de manière très
nuancée vous savez les mots sont très
agréables la sonorité ça compte bien sûr
dans une démocratie proximité
accessibilité apaisement de la société
moment donné il faut il faut gratter un
peu plus loin avoir le courage de
regarder ce qui s'est passé la police de
proximité et c'est normal que vous en
soyez ce leader je veux surtout pas
remettre en cause ce que le sens de
votre engagement mais la police de
proximité c'est une
invention du Parti socialiste et de
Lionel Jospin créé par Lionel Jos qui a
été décidé lors d'un congrès du Parti
socialiste qui est un congrès qui s'est
tenu à villepeinte et c'est une époque
où la gauche à juste titre d'ailleurs se
poser la question de savoir voir comment
prendre un virage disons
sécuritaire prenant en compte
c'est-à-dire l'évolution de la
délinquence de notre société des
aspirations de notre société et ainsi de
suite et donc ils ont imaginé ce
dispositif dispositif je vais le
préciser qui effectivement a été remise
en cause par Nicolas Sarkozi et les
ministres de l'Intérieur qui lui ont
succédé et jusqu'en 2012 à partir de
2012 on est entré dans le grand flou
parce que on avait les mots pour dire
qu'on allait y revenir puis finalement
on l'a pas tellement fait que je
comprends Sexte c'est que vous nous
dites que le Parti socialiste a créé
cela finalement comme un instrument
politique ben c'est normal d'ailleurs ça
c'est pas c'est tout à fait normal moi
ce que je dis simplement vous savez
c'est pour ça que je dis moment donné
les mots sont importants bien sûr mais
ce qui compte c'est les résultats la
vérité c'est que le bilan de cette
police de proximité et là aussi je suis
aussi nuancé que par ma réaction par
rapport à mon interlocuteur c'est que le
bilan a été très mitigé quand je vous le
dis j'étais sarkoziste j'étais ministre
de l'Intérieur sarkoziste peut-être que
ça peut être suspect mais vous avez la
personnalité qui l'a mise en place qui
est un haut fonctionnaire de police
Patrice bergouou directeur général de la
police nationale vous en souvenez qui
donc appliqué qui était très engagé
lui-même qui a donc appliqué la
politique et lui-même a dit que le bilan
était extrêmement mitigé et ce qui est
tout simple ce qui apparaît très
simplement et là pardon ça balait tout
ce que vous venez de dire d'une phrase
je suis désolé de vous de vous le vous
le souligner c'est que c'est très simple
sous Jospin la délinquence générale a
augmenté sous Sarkozy de 2002 à 2011 la
délinquence globale a baissé les crimes
et dél ont baissé de 17
% ces deux él mais ça ré n pas de
réponse ce sont des chiffres ça ce sont
c'est totalement objectif et il a le
droit d'y répondre je termine juste le
tour de table pour avoir l'avis
l'opinion de nos interlocuteurs ici
présent sur cette police de proximité
est-ce une erreur d'avoir supprimé la
police de proximité n'était-ce qu'un
outil politique au bilan très mitigé
mais de là où je vous parle en ma
qualité de sociologue j'ai envie de vous
dire que tout est question de point de
vue et puis ce que vous venez de dire et
ce que vous venez de dire l'illustre
assez bien finalement on l'a vu dans le
dans le documentaire aussi tout dépend
de la vision de la définition qu'on se
donne du rôle de la police moi j'ai pas
à me prononcer là-dessus mais je crois
que enfin on est tous d'accord autour de
la table pourû que le rôle des policiers
c'est d'interpeller c'est de réprimer si
nécessaire enfin c'est leur job il y a
pas de sujet là-dessus tout le monde
tout le monde est d'accord mais effec le
résultat je partage mais je pense c'est
plus global que ça le rôle c'est
d'identifier le
délinquant
l'interpeller le déférer et le faire
condamner c'est les quatre et quand il y
a un des quatre éléments de la chaîne
qui ne fonctionne pas c'est là où tout
d'un coup la société prend peur alors
alors pardon je fin en amont avant votre
qu de point il y a aussi prévenir
prévenir dans le sens où c'est éviter
que des méf soient commis éviter qu'il y
ait des victimes et de ce point de
vue-là il me semble que interpellation
investigation bien sûr que c'est le rôle
de la police mais reconnaître que la
prévention fait aussi partie et
pleinement partie du job pour le dire
comme ça ça me paraît de ce point de
vue-l demandons au premier concerné
Denis Jacob policier lui-même la police
son action c'est prévention dissuasion
répression euh il faut les trois euh
pour autant par rapport à ce que disait
le le directeur général de gendarmerie
bon le le le reportage l'aborde un peu
l'opposition police gendarmerie je
rappelle quand même que 85 % des fêes
délinquences sont en zone police hein
donc on on on n'aborde pas la question
de la prévention et de la proximité de
la même manière euh moi je voudrais
faire un petit rappel euh comme monsieur
le ministre l'a fait historique la
police de proximité proximité elle n'est
pas née avecel Jospin elle existait déjà
avant c'est-à-dire elle existait dans
les faits vous vou dire oui j'étais
hîotier ah oui j'étais hîotier au cœur
de la ville dans laquelle il y avait des
commissariats de quartier dans les
années 90 tout a été démantelé pour
diverses raisons et on a mis un terme à
l'îleotage d'accord ensuite il y a eu la
police de proximité de Lionel Jospin que
vous regrettez ou pas vous c'est pas une
question de la regretter c'est c'est
c'est elle a été faite de manière
inadaptée c'est-à-dire que la police de
proximité c'est utile c'est
complémentaire au reste de l'action de
police mais on a voulu aller vite on l'a
généralisé partout alors qu'on aurait dû
le faire de manière chirurgicale là où
il y en avait besoin je rappelle quand
même que quand la police de proximité
est supprimée par Nicolas Sarkozy on est
aussi dans un contexte très particulier
je rappelle qu'en 2001 deux policiers se
sont fait tuer que il y a un mouvement
de mécontentement puisqueen 2001 on a
fait un grand mouvement de manifestation
policière t syndicat confondu on était
plus de 30000 dans la rue à l'époque
c'est quand même il y a un contexte de
mécontentement policier où il y a une
demande justifiée et légitime des
collègues de dire nous avons besoin de
plus de moyens pour pouvoir avoir la
capacité de lutter contre la délinquence
et la criminalité et c'est de là qu'on
est arrivé avec la politique de Nicolas
Sarkozi qui était plus axé sur la police
sécuritaire répressive avec et monsieur
le ministre s'en souvient très bien un
plan quand mêmeord pluriannuel sur 8 ans
de 2 milliards et demi donc donc il faut
le rappeler quand même et ça cétait
attendu par les policiers TR piliers
parmi les trois piliers vous avez parlé
de la prévention est-ce que c'est comme
cela qu'on vous présente les choses
quand vous devenez policier est-ce qu'on
vous dit vous ferez aussi de la
prévention est-ce que ça fait
officiellement partie des piliers de la
police ou pas ça fait partie du piliers
de la la police bien évidemment mais
c'est une pédagogie globale que l'on a
en école de police en tous les cas je
parle parce que je commence à avoir un
peu d'ancienneté dans la maison ça fait
35 ans que je suis fonctionnaire de
police donc j'ai vu évoluer euh la
police l'émission de police j'ai j'ai
vécu toutes les réformes successives
qu'on a vécu parce que on en a quand
même eu quelques-unes la prévention on
nous l'apprend dans dans la relation
qu'on a avec la population mais
aujourd'hui la police nationale elle
n'est plus dans une démarche de police
de proximité et le comparatif qui est
fait aujourd'hui avec la police belge
tronque ah le débat c'est un exemple
très intéressant et si vous permettez on
y viendra juste après avec un extrait
Jérôme Durin je vous laisse répondre oui
sur la question qu'a abordé le ministre
ortefeu
euh on est on est passé quand même dans
une logique qui était extrêmement
quantitative la politique du chiffre et
puisque vous m'ameniez sur la question
des des comparatifs de chiffres il y a
eu à l'époque une mise en place
d'indicateurs qui ont été très contestés
et abandonnés d'ailleurs sur la
délinquence et cette focalisation sur le
chiffre euh sur la quantité de de délit
de de personnes arrêté elle nous a un
peu pe fait oublier tout ce qu'il y a
dans le documentaire euh une dimension
beaucoup plus qualitative qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans la société aujourd'hui si
on arrête avec l'histoire et si on
regarde la société aujourd'hui on a une
tension assez marquée entre la police et
la population certaines parties de la
population mais globalement la
population et on a une police qui est
souvent un petit peu à distance et qui
est vu comme j'allais dire la police du
prince contre c'est pas la police des
citoyens en tout cas c'est pas comme ça
que c'est vécu donc quand on entend
parler dans le reportage de présence de
contact r deabilité j'ai noté de
transparence de visibilité de
discernement c'est pas inintéressant
quand même pour des citoyens dans une
république de sentir qu'on on est en
communauté de valeur avec les policiers
sauf que ce que vous dites on peut plus
l'appliquer tout ce que vous venez de
dire tout tout ce que vous avez cité
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui le fait
d'avoir quitté la cité en tant que
policier et ça date d'avant la police de
proximité de Jospin on y était de
manière pérenne moi j'y travaillais du
matin jusqu'au soir h on en est sorti et
on a laissé le terrain à certains noyau
dur de délinquence ilut donc aujourd'hui
pour y revenir on va pas y aller la
fleur au fusil ça ça c'est c'est le
monde des bisounours et et et et et
aujourd'hui euh bien évidemment qu'il
faut essayer de reconquérir ces terrain
làà par une présence de la police mais
si on croit un seul instant que ce sera
par la seule action de la police on se
trompe je le dis depuis des années tant
qu'on naccompagnera pas la mission de
police avec un plan interministériel de
politique soci
de la ville on rglera rien on attend
aujourd'hui de la police qu' règle tout
ce qui n'est pas possible je vous laisse
r exactement ENF pardon je partage ce
sentimenté Nicolas Sarkozi avait sorti
une phrase c'est celle-ci qui avait fait
un peu polémique c'est les policiers
sont pas des travailleurs sociaux mais
effectivement chacun il l'avait dit dans
son déplacement à Toulouse en souvenit
çaavait pas tellement plus au directeur
départemental qu'il a pas bien vécu mais
pourtant c'est ça la réalité et parce
que s'il y a bien nécessité de
prévention je vous évoquz le mot mais
pardon d'abord dans mon esprit je n'ai
pas changé d'avis la première des
prévention c'est la certitude de la
sanction c'est ça la première des
préventions bon mais bien sûr qu'il y a
d'autres éléments qui doivent
accompagner mais c'est pas le rôle du
policier et j'entends ce que vous ce que
vous dites il faut pas se se fixer trop
sur les résultats de les les agrégats
d'abord ça je vous en remercie parce que
moi ça me rajunit parce que quand vous
parlez politique du chiffre ça me
rappelle ces quelques années que j'ai
beaucoup aimé quand j'étais ministre de
l'intérieur où je m vertué à dire mais
non c'est pas la politique du chiffre
c'est la politique du résultat ce que
l'on veut c'est donner des résultats à
nos concitoyens alors quand vous parlez
de police de proximité vous savez on a
un exemple vous le connaissez j'imagine
c'est ce qu' décidé Paris la ville de
Paris la ville de Paris a redéployé 3400
agents c'est très présent dans le
documentaire c'est cette police
municipale va vir résultat non mais
attendez résultat quand on voit le
résultat moi je serai honnêtement vous
savez moi j'ai passé làâ des polémiques
et cette étape de ma vie publique
franchement si c'était bien je dirais
c'est bien c'est tout c'est il y a rien
de compliqué mais quel est le résultat
vous apercevez que vous avez une
augmentation des volets avec violence de
plus de 20 24 %, 24,6 %. vous apercevez
que vous avez une augmentation des
cambriolages de plus de 25 % vous
apercevez que tous les agrégats de
cambrillolage plus de 9 % donc vous
dites c'est peut-être très sympathique
peut-être que c'est agréable mais c'est
pas ça le film met en avant l'exemple de
la police belge de proximité et je vais
vous donner la parole Virginie maloché
après cet extrait on l'appelle là-bas la
police locale elle a été décidée en 98
suite à des dysfonctionnements mis au
jour par l'affaire du trou elle a pris
effet en 2001 et sa mission depuis plus
de 20 ans c'est justement d'être sur le
terrain au plus près du citoyen et dans
une logique d'enracinement local alors
est-ce le bon modèle vous allez me le
dire juste après cet extrait qu'on a
choisi et qu'on a écourté
tout va bien
ouim ça bien vous pouvez dormir je
voulais être sûr que tout le monde va
bien et vous êtes de passage chez
nous consommer les boissons alcoolisées
non les amis derrière ils sont endormis
là
aussi c'est permis de conduire monsieur
le permis de conduire pas les papiers de
la voiture juste votre permis de
conduire à
vousi c'est aussi un papier comme ça
OK
pvez venir avec moi à l'instant on va
aller jusqu'à la camionette là-bas s'il
vous
plaît Virginie maloch qu'avez-vous pensé
de cette exemple belge qui est frappant
effectivement he vu de France où les
policiers ne font pas cela alors ça
dépend ça dépend où ça dépend lesquels
et on parle là de l'exemple belge plus
précisément de l'exemple du secteur de
Paul Bruno parce que le le comment dire
c ce cas de figure Paul Bruno n'est pas
forcément révélateur significatif de la
manière dont fonctionneent toutes les
zones plur belge parce qu'il y a de la
diversité là encore et c'est
probablement tant mieux c'est vrai aussi
dans dans nos polices françaises au
pluriel puisqu'on parlait des polices
municipales également et et probablement
que l'on que l'on y reviendra qu'il
s'agisse de ce cas belge puisque vous
posez la question de savoir si ça peut
nous nous inspirer ou des autres
programmes des autres expériences de ce
type je vais dire rapidement police de
proximité mais le terme est tellement
miné con noté maintenant le dire mais
disons une police ancré dans les
territoires et tourn vers la population
pour le dire pour le dire rapidement
plusieurs questions à se poser la
première c'est effectivement vous la
souleviez celle de l'efficacité du
modèle mais là encore pour se prononcer
là-dessus tout dépend des objectifs des
objec exactement là-dessus à l'échelle
internationale disons les évaluations
disponibles à ce sujet que nous
disent-ell globalement
qu'effectivement si l'on prend le
critère tau de délinquence pour le dire
comme ça il y a pas forcément
d'incidence notoire en revanche ça
dépend des cas de figure mais
globalement en revanche ce type de
police là joue très positivement sur le
sentiment d'insécuritéord et ce n'est
pas que pour être une police plus
agréable hein quand les gens se sentent
davantage en sécurité ils investissent
aussi plus l'espace public ils s'y
sentent plus à l'aise et cela en soi ça
concourt aussi à la sécurisation au
contrôle social classique informel pour
le pour le dire comme ça et puis
aussiord ça peut jouer positivement sur
le niveau de satisfaction
professionnelle des policiers on est
presque sur des effets psychologiques en
fait ass c'est peu mesurable compliqué à
mesurer ça peut se mesurer il il y a des
dispositifs méthodologiques qui
permettent de le faire mais surtout ça
joue positivement sur l'image que les
gens ont des forces de l'ordre ont de la
population et ça en soi c'est important
on pourrait dire ah bah tiens c'est
qu'une opération de com après tout ouais
pas que parce que parce que si l'on
considère que précisément l'amélioration
de l'image de la police l'amélioration
du rapport police population pour le
dire comme ça ça a aussi des effets qui
sont bénéfiques sur les conditions d' pe
sujet Jérôme dur je vous donne la parole
ensuite den Jacob oui la police la
sécurité c'est un service public on se
plain beaucoup des autres services
publics l'éducation la santé c'est aussi
un service public dans lequel il y a des
fonctionnaires qui ont le droit d'avoir
des conditions de travail satisfaisantes
et il y a aussi des usagers qui ont le
droit de se sentir bien traité par ce
service public là et et je pense que
quand on parle de l'autre police parce
que c'est comme ça que vous avez amené
le débat l'autre police ça
par rapport à la police actuelle donc on
cherche autre chose alors est-ce que
c'est la police municipale je pense
qu'on y reviendra tout à l'heure est-ce
que c'est autre chose en tout cas la
demande sociale et et parfois la demande
des fonctionnaires de police eux même
qui sont pas toujours satisfaits tout c
un syndicaliste qui disait une époque on
était dans les quartiers envie d'
retourner c'est pas possible ce que vous
avez dit d'ailleurs à l'instant c'est
peut-être pas possible pour l'instant
mais moi je pense que c'est souhaitable
et que de toute façon avec d'autres
acteurs de de la de la société on doit
reconstruire une place pour la police où
on n'est pas simplement sur cette espèce
de rhtorique autoritaire martiale
interpellation ce que disit un peu
Nicolas Sarkozy en raillant la police de
proximité et aujourd'hui quand on voit
les les les sujets les refus
d'obtempérés l'affire Naël euh les
policiers qui sont victimes de violence
les questions de contrôle d'identité
dont on se dit est-ce que les gens vous
vous dites une telle police retisserait
un lien mais il faut il faut il faut
retisser un lien et il y a une dimension
qualitative une dimension relationnelle
la police de la républque la police des
citoyens dans laquelle ils se
reconnaissent et vis-àvis de laquelle
ils sonentent considérés parce que le le
film met en avant l'exemple belge mais
il n'y a pas que la Belgique he qui a
une police de proximité il y a l'exemple
londonien les forces de l'ordre anglais
sont souvent qualifié de meilleur police
du monde d'ailleurs le la métropolitain
police définie ainsi par son ancien chef
Bernard Ogan ha nos agents de quartier
ceux qui connaissent les rues de leur
quartiers et les noms de nombreuses
personnes de leur district sont notre
arme principal ils sont nos yeux et nos
oreilles une police de proximité
londonienne là aussi c'est une nécessité
de de pouvoir reconquérir des endroits
où on intervient aujourd'hui que pour
intervenir et mettre un terme à un acte
de délinquence de criminalité et ensuite
repartir bien évidemment que c'est c'est
important mais moi où je suis pas
satisfait de ce qui a été montré dans ce
documentaire c'est un peu le le le
prisme dogmatique et très partial de
prendre en exemple la police belge en la
prenant comme la panassée la panassée
pour la France alors que la police
locale de la Belgique ce n'est ni plus
ni moins que la police municipale en
France je rappelle qu'en 1998 la police
fédérale la
gendarmerie belge et la police locale a
fusionné et de cette fusion ils ont
refait deux branche la police fédérale
et la police locale la police locale en
Belgique elle est sous l'autorité des
élus elle est pas sous l'autorité de
l'État donc c'est la police municipale
en France et là on on dit bah en fait ça
il faudrait que ce soit la police
nationale qui le fasse non plus
aujourd'hui plus dans le contexte actuel
donc il faut des polices municipales
partout brisortefeu non mais je complète
juste parce que vous avez parfaitement
raison c'est que les formes de la
délinquence sont aussi considérablement
évolué les moyens technologiques
l'armement qui est utilisé on n plus
dans l'époque à l'époque précisément des
années 2000 ça a complètement changé et
d'ailleurs déjà dans les années 2000 un
des défauts de la police j'allais dire
josp c'est pas TR schématisé mais c'est
que elle était dans la journée la nuit
elle existait
pas on voyait pas de bleu la nuit hein
c'était c'était donc enfin la la société
heureusement elle est pas figée et donc
elle a considérablement changé et c'est
pour ça que je vous dis on on sera
obligé
inéluctablement d'arriver à un schéma
dans lequel il y aura police locale
c'est-à-dire police municipale pour
l'essentiel et la police d'État qui sera
la police d'intervention et
d'inationens de une locale une nationale
mais alors pourquoi pas de police
municipout sujet très important si je
peux me permettre c'est et on en discuté
tout à l'heure avec monsieur le sénateur
et on est on est en phase le rôle de la
police municipale en France aujourd'hui
elle est présentée comme une force
supplétive à la police nationale demain
elle doit être identifiée comme la vraie
troisème force de sécurité intérieure en
France et aujourd'hui qui est en premier
contact de la population dans certains
quartiers en France c'est plus la police
nationale c'est la police municipale
mais après il y a le débat de la police
municipale que l'on a en fonction des
communes et et qui la paye qui la
finance dernier élément parce que pour
compléter parce que là aussi pardon je
juste d'une phrase ça évolu vous avez
raison il y a la police nationale il y a
la police d'État et il y a la police
municipale et n'oubliez pas maintenant
la branche qui existe aussi c'est la
sécurité privée il faut naturalement en
tenir compte parce que la proximité
c'est pourquoi développe-telle pourquoi
se développet-elle la bah parce que la
société a évolué donc la société a bougé
le for de délinquence et vous voyez bien
on le voit tous on fait nos courses on
il y a des police des polices privées
donc c'est quelque chose là aussi qui
est inéluctable jérô Durin oui sur sur
ces sujets moi je suis je suis un
sénateur socialiste un homme de gauche
et et et je crois qu'on aborde
aujourd'hui dans ma famille politique
ces questions sans candur sans naïveté
c'est vrai sans candur s Naé quand
j'étais avec
les la brave la brave le 1er mai euh je
vais pas vous dire que face aux
manifestants au black block il faut des
policiers de proximité qui viennent
parler de la plie du B temp donc
là-dessus il faut qu'on soit très clair
euh ce qui est important dans les débats
de ces dernières années c'est
l'évolution vers le continuum de
sécurité c'est la loi sécurité globale
euh où on nous a expliqué qu'il y avait
police gendarmerie euh police municipale
force de sécurité privée le problème
c'est le c'est la question qui a été
très bien posée c'est à quoi servent les
polices municipales est-ce qu'on peut
accepter dans un état comme le nôtre que
certaines fonctions régaliennes soient
dévolues à des polices municipales qui
existent ou qui n'existe pas ma voisine
c'est documenté ces choses-là qui sont
armées ou qui ne le sont pas dont les
doctrines d'emploi sont différentes d'un
endroit à l'autre certaines sont très
axé sur une dimension ressive je pense à
certains coins du sud de la France au
bord de la mare Méditerranée où on a des
polices municipal qui sont quasi la
police nationale dans leur conceptionord
donc il faudra définir les contours
précisément et les harmoniser bah en
tout cas c'est une vraie question est-ce
que devant le service public de la
sécurité on a le droit d'avoir une même
exigence partout sur le territoire
national oui est-ce que les polices
municipales s'emparent de ce sujet-là
mais si elles le font elles le font à la
place de la police nationale elles font
autre chose et ce sujet-là n'est pas
abouti par exemple la question de la
déontologie si on a des policiers
municipaux qui font comme les police
nationale la police nationale est-ce que
les obligations déontologiques elles
doivent s'appliquer à eux et où est-ce
que c'est contrôlé ça alors on l' vu
dans le reportage avecqu ton qui
intervient sur ce sujet pour la ville de
Paris c'est tout un champ qui reste à
éclaircir à quoi ça sert comment c'est
organisé quelles obligations et ça c'est
un choix politique global Virginie
maloch oui pour rebondir là-dessus parce
qu'il se trouve que ça fait 25 ans que
je bosse sur les police municipale et ça
fait 25 ans que j'entends dire que les
polices municipales c'est la seule vraie
police de proximité bon donc la
référence si vous voulez à la police de
proximité dans le monde des polices
municipales chez les maires tout
étiquette confondu comme chez une
majeure partie des agents cette
référence elle est fédératrice elle est
consensuelle mais elle est devenue
tellement consensuelle qu'elle nous dit
finalement plus grand-chose de la
manière dont on emploie effectivement
ces
polices ces polices locales ces polices
municipal ceci étant là encore si on
essaie de de regarder les choses de d'un
peu de manière un peu générale je vais
le dire comme ça si l'on s'en tient la
définition classique commune de la
police de proximité celle qui est V ul
dans le reportage alors là le constat
c'est effectivement que la tendance
c'est celle d'un glissement vers un
modèle c'est c'est pas du tout un
jugement de valeur de ma part que de le
dire comme ça mais vers un modèle qui
est plus interventionniste et répressif
il a pas que moi qui le dit la Cour des
comptes les récents rapports
parlementaires sur le sujet ce
glissement là il est encouragé par le
législateur accroissement continue des
prérogatives des policiers municipaux
depuis allez
1999 maintenant c'est évident pas sans
incidence sur la nature du rapport avec
le public donc ce que je veux simplement
dire c'est que c'est pas parce que ces
polices là sont locales qu'elles jouent
forcément la carte de la police de
proximité hein dans cette redéfinition
du à vos arguments faut rappeler que
s'il y a des prérogative élargie aux
polices municipales elle restent dans
leur cadre de leur qualification d'agent
de police judiciaire adjoint donc c'est
quand même c'est quand même limité hein
je le rappelle ils sont sous l'autorité
d'un officier de police judiciaire de la
police nationale donc c'est quand quand
même limité mais il faut reconnaître le
travail de la police municipale c'est
d'ailleurs ce que les agents demandent
sur sur la
proximité la différence entre un
policier municipal d'aujourd'hui et le
policier national d'hier ilotier c'est
que tous les deux au départ était issu
de la cité moi quand j'étais hotier la
plupart de mes collègues résidaient sur
la commune demander aujourd'hui un
policier national de résider sur la
commune où il travaille mais là c'est la
femme les enfants agressés je vais pas
faaire le débat aujourd'hui on cache aux
enfants le fait de dire qu'on est papa
et maman policier parce que à l'école
voilà ça va se savoir et puis tout ce
qui peut y avoir derrière aujourd'hui
les policiers municipaux sont les
policiers nationaux d'hier qui sont pour
la plupart issu de de la commune de la
ville aujourd'hui aujourd'hui allez
demander à des policiers du 93 de faire
de la police de proximité alors que ça
tourne tous les 3 4 ans tous les 3 4 ans
ils viennent ils partent enfin c'est
c'est un vrai sujet hein aussi pour la
police nationale alors la police de
proximité en tant que telle a disparu
mais finalement fil nous le confirme on
a sur le territoire toutes sortes
d'entités qui font de la proximité il y
a la police de sécurité du quotidien
dont on n pas encore parlé lancer par
Emmanuel Macron en 2018 cette police
municipal dont vous parlez réinstauré à
Paris en 2021 et puis il y a l'annonce
présidentielle il y a quelques jours de
brigades de gendarmerie 238 brigades de
gendarmerie vous me donnerez votre avis
dans un instant mais la gendarmerie qui
elle nous le dit clairement dans le film
elle fait de la proximité écoutez al
estce que la gendarmerie fait de la
police de proximité en fait on nous a
demandé de faire la sécurité du
quotidien ça vraiment été une une
impultion forte du ministre on est
exactement là-dedans il y a un lien de
confiance nécessaire si on veut que
l'action de la gendarmerie soit
considérée comme légitime auprès de la
population et pour ça il faut être
auprès des gens et en fait on a
construit toutes les modalités modalités
d'action et l'accomplissement de nos
missions sur cette notion de proximité
le le gendarme il doit être de dehors il
doit être au contact il doit être sur le
marché il doit être au contact des
élus bris sortefeu la gendarmerie fait
de la proximité le revendique oui mais
ça a été rappelé en en début
d'émission la situation en police
gendarmerie n'est pas la même moi j'ai
j'ai eu l'honneur d'être le premier
ministre de l'intérieur c'est le hasard
du calendrier hein très honnêtement mais
Premier ministre de l'Intérieur à avoir
directement sous mon autorité la police
et la gendarmerie avant c'était une
autorité d'emploi là j'avais
symboliquement installé le directeur
général de la gendarmerie dans les
locaux du ministère de l'intérieur ils
ont toujours naturellement le
le Moulineau mais ils étaient
symboliquement installés donc j'ai j'ai
pu
voir vous l'avez rappelé en début
d'émission l'essentiel des faits de
délinquence se font en zone police mais
l'essentiel du territoire est en zone
gendarmerie voyez donc il y a une
répartition qui est très très différente
mais le modèle n'est-il pas duplicable
n'est-il pas
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas reproduire ce
que fait la gendarmerie dans les
territoires ou effectivement la densité
poulation méth le façon de faire pense
que la la distinction qui existe
aujourd'hui est une distinction utile
car c'est des ce sont des actions qui
sont complémentaires donc il y a
effectivement ces deux forces
régaliennes qui sont complémentaires
mais parce qu'elles ont des champs
d'application des territoires
d'application qui sont qui sont
différents aucune inspiration possible
de l'une vers l'autre moi je suis l'élu
d'un d'un département rural je sénateur
de de son et noir
donc il est vrai que l'essentiel des
crimes et délit est commis dans les
unités urbaine en zone police enfin
l'essentiel de la population il est
aussi en zone police donc il y a quand
même cet élément qu'il faut il faut pas
présenter les zones gendarmerie comme
des endroits où il se passe rien on a on
a de la violence routière on a des
stupéfiants on a des violences
intrafamilial on a tout toutes sortes de
criminalité la délinqu écique environ
donc il il y a tout ça en gendarmerie
mais ce qui fait que ça marche en
gendarmerie sur la dimension proximité
c'est précisément ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure monsieur c'est que il y a
une immersion des gendarmes dans leur
terrain de vie parce que une une
gendarmerie c'est un c'est des bureaux
mais c'est aussi un espace pour les
familles les gendarmes ils habitent le
territoire où ils travaillent et donc
ils sont immergés comme les policiers
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure et et
donc du coup ça crée quand même un lien
euh un lien très particulier avec la
population parce qu'on est voit parce
qu'on les connaît parce qu'ils sont là
et et et le référentiel n'est quand même
pas le même gendarmerie oui en France
elle est réputée effectivement comme
étant plus enraciné pour dire comme ça
et plus proche de la population que la
police nationale globalement et
traditionnellement c'est vrai qu'il y a
un maillage territorial une une culture
professionnelle des modes opératoires
qui sont plus propices pour le dire
comme ça à la proximité et ce cœur de
métier historique de l'ARG de la
gendarmerie centré sur le contact
l'insertion locale comme vous disiez la
la proximité il est quand même contrarié
ces dernières ces derniers temps ces
dernières années pour plein de raisons
qui tiennent d'abord à l'évolution des
territoires couverts par la gendarmerie
hein parce que parce que après tout dans
certaines zones périurbaines il y a pas
grand-chose à envier par rapport à
certaines à certaines zones urbaines en
tout cas les raisons pour lesquelles ce
ce ce cœur de métier historique est
aussi un peu bousculé en tout cas pour
lesquel la gendarmerie s'en éloigne ce
sont des qui tiennent aussi au
changement interne à la gendarmerie hein
précisément vous évquz ce ce
rattachement fonctionnel au ministère de
l'Intérieur je mets ple guillemets une
forme de policiarisation des missions de
la gendarmerie des restructurations des
implantations territoriales par parce
que s'il y a aujourd'hui cette annonce
de 238 nouvell brigades don une majeur
partie sont des brigades mobiles soit
soit dit en passassant mais en tout cas
s'il y a cette annonce là c'est bien
pour répondre à des attentes à des
besoins qui remontent de la part des
élus locaux et pour d'une certaine
manière retricoter ce qui a pu être
détricoté antérieurement très rapidement
un dernier tour de table avec vous tous
avec cette question qui fera office de
conclusion comment retisser un lien
entre la police et la population deis
Jacob B très brièvement c'est en ne
comptant pas uniquement sur la seule
action de la police là où on doit
retisser ce lien avec la population
reconquérir les terrains par des actions
je le dis très très librement de
répression pour éad qui est les noyaux
dur de la délinquence qui pourrissent
ces quartiers où la grande majorité de
la population n'aspire qu'à une chose
hein c'est y vivre comme n'importe quel
citoyen ailleurs en France et d'avoir un
véritable plan Marchal de reconquête des
quartiers par une politique de la ville
une politique sociale une politique
économique parce qu'effectivement le
policier il peut pas tout faire sor feu
d'abord une première réalité c'est que
l'immense majorité de la population
soutient la police et s tient la
gendarmerie donc on dit bien sûr qu'il
faut retisser mais il y a une adhésion
bon et deuxème
élément pour que la population
reconnaisse la police et la gendarmerie
il faut qu'elle obtienne des résultats
vous savez quand vous êtes cambriolé
aujourd'hui vous avez en réalité 92
chances sur 100 qu'on ninterpelle jamais
celui jamais en tout cas dans l'année
qui suit qu'on interpelle celui qui est
le responsable du cambriolage bah on
fait évoluer le résultat et bien vous
verrez tout de suite que la population
sera extrêmement reconnaissante si le
taux d'élucidation pr pour avoir
confiance il faut qu'il y ait des
résultats donc il faut la politique du
résultat Jérome Durin oui je suis pas
d'accord avec ça parce que je pense que
ce qui peut retisser le lien entre la
police et la population c'est pas
répondre à une crise de l'efficacité et
d'ailleurs les les ce qui s'est passé
avant l'été
ù les difficultés dont on a parlé qui
ont par exemple généré le beauau de la
sécurité je pense à l'affaire Michel
zcller ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'efficacité c'est peut-être parfois
peut-être un peu trop d'efficacité donc
il y a un sujet de formation La
formation ça a été dans le dernier
mandat un truc un peu compliqué quand
même l' on l' on l'a baissé en terme de
temps après on l'a augmenté il y a un
problème de recrutement parce que les
les effectifs qu'il faut reconstituer
c'est un vrai sujet le niveau de
recrutement est un problème aussi et il
y a quelques symboles sur lesquels il
faut jouer c'est pas vrai partout sur
tous les territoires de la République
mais dans certains territoires de la
République je pense au contrôle
d'identité je pense au refus
d'obtempérer il y a des symboles qui
doivent rapprocher la police de la
population et ça il faut qu'on y
travaille tous Virginie
oui en travaillant sur l'adhésion des
policiers des agendas bases parce que
c'est deux dont tout dépend quand même
dans l'affaire en tout cas des agents de
police de voie publique je parle de ce
que je connais pas des autres métiers
policiers sur leur adhésion précisément
à une orientation davantage tourner vers
la population et pour travailler à cette
adhésion je rebondis sur ce que vous
disiez il faut évidemment tenir compte
des difficultés réell du métier et et de
la manière dont les policiers vivent
leur métier parce qu'il y a aussi
beaucoup une question de rapport il y a
évidemment des enjeux d'évolution de la
délinquence de la violence que je ne ni
pas il y a aussi beaucoup une question
de rapport au public à l'environnement
et c'est cela qu'il s'agit de travailler
en premier lieu il y a encore des
policiers qui sont très intégrés dans
leur quartier qu'ils vivent bien qui
passe partout c'est pas pour autant
qu'il laisse passer les choses et
heureusement et ceuxà généralement ne se
sentent pas menacés dans leur
environnement et créent les condition
d'une intervention plus apaisée ce n'est
pas qu'un mot plus apaisé et donc plus
efficace aussi
on s'arrêtera sur ces mots merci merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cet échange merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi comme chaque semaine
émission et documentaire à retrouver sur
notre plateforme publicsenat.fr à très
vite sur publicsenat
[Musique]
merci